et on continue d'en parler avec en
direct avec notre invité rémy pérard et
les délégué national du syndicat
étudiant uni bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur la qualité france
alors première question est quelle est
votre réaction suite à cette annonce
bah écoutez on remarque encore que le
gouvernement ne règle le problème des
étudiants et de la précarité étudiante
avec des mesurettes on le voit on l'a vu
pendant la crise sanitaire on a vu
pendant les confinements successifs qui
avait une sorte
d'incompréhension de la précarité pour
les étudiants et même de mépris de la
part du gouvernement alors que nous ce
qu'on demande que l'uni demande depuis
des années ce sont des réformes
structurelles sur le système de bourse
parce que actuellement les thèmes de
bourse le concerne absolument pas les
classes moyennes par exemple qui
souffrent de plus en plus on a aussi
demandé la mise en place d'un ticket de
restauration étudiants sur le même
modèle que celui des salariés le sénat
l'a adopté à une large majorité et le
gouvernement s'est refusé à l'appliquer
elle mettre en place
ces derniers jours donc on voit bien que
le gouvernement
ne se sert d'eux se sert de la précarité
étudiante pour faire des effets
d'annoncé mais pas pour faire des
réformes structurelles de fond donc
c'est donc une mesure est selon-vous
real annonce de jean castex ne savais
même pas si les étudiants allaient être
concernés par cette annonce et puis
après une précision de gabriella talent
c'est quand même un petit pas si j'ose
dire non
ecoutez-la ce que vous soulignez c'est
surtout la préparation du gouvernement
sur cette question on
fait ça fait des années ça fait deux ans
au moins deux ans qu'on appelle le
gouvernement à réagir sur cette
précarité et sur les besoins des
étudiants on a vu encore depuis la
rentrée universitaire les files
d'attentes devant les distributions
alimentaires devant les épiceries sont
encore très très longues et donc c'est
pas avec une annonce de jean castex qui
n'est même pas très précises pour le
pour la communauté étudiante qu'on va
aller bien loin donc finalement c'est
une refonte totale du système de bourse
quand vous demandez aujourd'hui tout à
fait tout à fait c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'on appelle la linéarisation du
système de bourses qui serait donc plus
favorable notamment aux étudiants comme
je le disais de classes moyennes qui
sont trop riche pour être pauvre et trop
pauvre pour être riches qui sont entre
les deux et qui ne bénéficient jamais
d'aucune aide en plus de tous les
étudiants qui sont déjà boursiers et qui
ne perçoivent pas assez de débit alors
vous êtes un délégué national du
syndicat étudiant uni vous êtes bons
coups au plus proche un des étudiants
pouvez vous nous dire à quel point
justement cette crise sanitaire a frappé
de plein fouet dans le portefeuille des
étudiants
mais comme je vous le disais on a vu des
files d'attentes à nos distributions
alimentaires on a eu malheureusement
organisé beaucoup de ces distributions à
travers toute la france et à chaque fois
les étudiants venaient nous voir nous
disant on est on est déjà satisfait
certes qu' il y ait plus de distance
yale que l'on puisse revenir un petit
peu en présentiel même si c'est pas le
cas partout malheureusement mais ça va
pas encore assez loin il ya encore des z
à offrir des des petits boulots à
trouver pour les étudiants parce que il
faut aussi que qu'on puisse chacun se
responsabiliser et le problème c'est que
sur aucun d'eux si je suis une ce sujet
là nous sommes sommés d vous n'avez pas
été tenu au courant de cette prime de
100 euros vous n'avez pas non plus été
mis au courant du potentiel calendrier
par la part à cette aide de 100 euros
pour les étudiants
absolument pas et ça relève encore une
fois de l'amateurisme et de
l'impréparation du gouvernement et
justement pour les conditions des
étudiants pour avoir accès à ces aides
il faut qu'ils soient fiscalement
autonome ça veut dire quoi précisément
mais ça veut dire qu'il ne serait pas
sur le sur la déclaration de leurs de
leurs parents probablement mais encore
une fois il ya beaucoup d'étudiants qui
sont toujours sur la déclaration fiscale
de leurs parents donc là encore il ya
une il ya une déconnexion totale des
mesures voulues par le gouvernement
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous proposez
concrètement pour venir en aide à ses
étudiants
comme je vous ai dit nous on n'a en des
temps et on le défendra encore le ticket
restaurant étudiants pour venir en aide
aux étudiants sur le plan alimentaire
c'est à dire que grâce à ce ticket resto
les étudiants pourraient se rendre
toujours au restaurant universitaire
mais aussi en
magasin etc pour pouvoir s'alimenter
parce que c'est ça qui qui coûte le plus
cher après évidemment le loyer c'est
cesser l'alimentation et c'est
primordial le problème c'est que le
gouvernement refuse de faire un pas vers
nous sur cette question pour des raisons
complètement idéologique alami paiera
remercie d'avoir été en direct avec nous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué national
du syndicat étudiant uni merci à vous